نتحدث مع سلام خضر عن
النواحي الانسانيه التي رصدتها في جولتها
وسلام خضر كما تابعت مشاهدينا تنقلت في
اكثر من ولايه من غازي عنتاب الى عثمانيه
والى ملاطيا هي الان في ولايه اليزار
وترصد لنا المشهد والاثار الانسانيه
بسبب هذا الزلزال وتداعياته اليك الكلمه
سلام
عبد السلام مدينه اللاذق تعتبر حاليا
الظهير الخلفي لملاطيا كونها تبعد عن
مدينه ملاطيا قرابه 30 كيلومتر ولم تتضرر
بشكل كبير وواسع بفعل الزلزال الذي وقع
قبل ثلاثه ايام هذه المدينه باتت الظهير
الخلفي من هنا يتم تجميع وارسال المساعدات
ايضا من هذا المكان يتم تزويد بعض
العائلات بالاحتياجات اليوميه الاساسيه
جدا نظرا ان المحل التجاريه لا تزال تعمل
في المدينه ويبدو ان هناك مخازن ايضا لا
تزال تعمل الفنادق هنا تستضيف مئات
العائلات الذين اضطروا لاخلاء منازلهم في
ملاطيابات الان زوارا في فنادق المدينه
لان لا شيء في مرض حاليا قادر على استقبال
اي شخص المباني بجلها تخضع حاليا لعمليه
فحص واسعه من قبل السلطات المختصه سواء
تضررت في الذي وقع او انها قد تكون مقاومه
لاي هزه ارتداديه قد تكون قويه اليوم
هزتان يعني
متوسطتان ضربتاه ملاطيا الواحده الاولى
صباحا والثانيه بعد ظهر هذا اليوم وتراوحت
حدتهما بين ثلاثه الى اربع درجات على
مقياس رختر الوضع في مالاطيه صعب جدا
البرد قارس كما ترى الدرجات الحراره تتدنى
ما دون السفر مئويه حتى خلال فترات النهار
لا تتوفر الكهرباء في ملاطيا وايضا لا
تتوفر امدادات الغاز الاساسيه
للمنازل التي لا تزال قادره او قاومت
الزلزال وهي قادره على ان يعود اليها
اصحابها ايضا شبكه المياه تضررت بشكل كبير
رغم ان الفرق اليوم فرق الاصلاح تعمل بشكل
خفيف في محاوله لاستعاده الخدمات لكن
الماس
الاقصى والاكثر فظاعه عبد عبد السلام تبقى
للعائلات خاصه الذين ينتظرون انتشال
احبائهم من تحت ركام المنازل التي انهارت
مرت اكثر من 60 ساعه هناك العشرات لا
يزالون عالقين تحت انقاض المباني فرق
الانقاذ المحليه لم تتوقف عن العمل منذ
لحظه وقوع الزلزال حينما وصلت الى مدينه
ملاطيا كما هي الحال في جميع المدن
التركيه اليوم بعد الظهر نحن تركنا ملاطيا
منذ تقريبا ساعتين دخلت اولى الفرق
الاجنبيه الاوروبيه في محاوله لاسناد
الفرق المحليه التي تعمل سواء من منظمات
محليه منظمه نفاد ايضا
يعني فرق البحث والانقاذ وايضا الجيش الذي
يعمل يعمل مساعدا ومساعدا اساسيا لهذه
الفرق